if you enjoy content like this please
subscribe to the lucid programming
channel for more programming tutorials
okay so in this video we'll be making
use of the twe P API and this is an API
that we can access via Python which will
allow us to very easily stream tweets in
real time directly from Twitter so in
order to follow this series of tutorials
what we're going to be doing is
installing tweet P which is a Python
package so I'm going to assume that you
have Python installed on your machine
and if so all we'll need is the twe P
module we're just going to create a
Python sorry well we are going to create
some Python we're going to first create
a Twitter application and in order to do
that you will also require a Twitter
account so if you don't have a Twitter
account go ahead and create one it's
pretty easy to do doesn't need to be a
main Twitter account or anything like
that you just need to sign up for
Twitter in whatever way you wish to do
so once you do that you will have the
ability to create a Twitter application
and then well write Python code that
will interface with that application to
stream tweets in real time based on
keywords or hashtags now what we'll do
in this video is we'll just write a very
simple application to accomplish just
that so we'll see tweets given a set of
keywords and then in later subsequent
videos we'll see what we can do to
analyze the content of the tweets that
we get back maybe we can produce some
nice graphs based on that data and then
some other fun things that we can do
with that data like possibly sentiment
analysis which will most likely be part
of the natural language processing
series of videos so keep an eye out for
that as well so I guess one thing that I
want to mention as well is that all of
the code as usual for all of these
things will be provided on the github
page and all the links that I'm talking
about here all the links that I have
opened on this browser are going to be
available below in the description so no
need to write them down but just refer
to that and you can see the code that we
use in this in all videos another thing
I want to mention too is that if you
have any problems or questions about
twee pea which is the primary module
that we will be using in this tutorial
series
the documentation is Doc's tweed org
again
link will be in the description and more
further information about this module is
there and it's very descriptive and well
written so I will refer you to that so
before we get into writing any Python
code as I mentioned we need to actually
go ahead and create a Twitter
application so in order to do that what
we need to do is navigate over to apps
Twitter comm again this will require
that you do have a Twitter account and
are logged in if so you should be
presented with a dashboard that looks
probably similar to this depending on
what time when you're watching this
video you can see that I already have an
application here listen to under my
Twitter apps that was used for something
else I was working on just for fun
and what were your going to want to do
you might not see anything here if you
don't have any apps in this application
management section you can click on this
create new app button that will take you
to a form which just asks for some
really simple details about what this
Twitter application is going to be doing
so I've already kind of did a dry run of
this and I have some information for
what will be filling in so you can put
in whatever name you like I'm going to
put in this name this is just the name
of the Twitter application lucid
programming Twitter app a description
which is also required so I'm just going
to say a test Twitter application for a
YouTube tutorial and then a website so
I'm just going to put in my own homepage
here just for good measure I suppose
callback URL this is not particularly
necessary so we'll just leave this blank
make sure you click this developer
agreement and then you can click on
create your Twitter application so if
you do so then you are presented
hopefully with this page that says your
application has been created and all of
the relevant information for your
application will be stored here in terms
of how to access
I guess credentials and things like that
so what you're going to want to do is
actually click on the Settings tab right
here so if you do so you will see a
you'll see four things listed consumer
key consumer secret access token and
access secret I'm not going to click on
that because the I guess the keys are
unique to each program and I guess
showing those things is I think it's
against well it might be in poor taste I
don't exactly know if there's any like
security breach if I share those things
but I guess just for good measure I'm
just going to let you click on let
yourself look at what those are keep
them secret and then we're going to use
those to interface with our application
I guess for one thing if you do have a
Twitter application that's interfacing
with Twitter you wouldn't want somebody
to get access to your tokens because
then they can manipulate it and they
could you know possibly abuse it and you
know that wouldn't look good for your
Twitter account so try not to let that
happen so we're going to use those four
credentials to authenticate the Python
program that we will now be writing so
with that said convey devise this and
let's get to writing some code so the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to create a credentials file which is
going to store those four things which
you should see on your settings tab so
I'm going to create this as Twitter
credentials dot pi so what we're going
to do here is we're just going to create
some variables which will be accessed in
our primary program so I'll just put in
a comment variables that contain the
user credentials to access Twitter API
so the first one is access token
the next is access token secret there's
also the consumer let me spell it
properly consumer key and the consumer
secrets so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to whoops I'm going to define
each of these is just Python strings so
I'm just going to assume that you can go
over to the Settings tab back to here
click on the Settings tab and then copy
and paste in between these quotes the
access token access token secret
consumer key and consumer secret save
this file and make sure that this file
is saved in the same directory that
you'll be using all of your that you'll
be writing all of your Twitter API
access Python code in so I'm just going
to save this right now
and that's that so if I look here I have
Twitter credentials pi in this directory
in the same directory I'm going to
create another Python file which will be
the brains of what we'll be doing which
as I mentioned before will just be in
this video at least streaming the tweets
directly from Twitter in a real time so
let's create a file which we'll call twe
P streamer PI so before we get into
writing this one thing that I probably
should have mentioned earlier than I did
is that oops that was not supposed to go
there let's see let's try that again
there we go you need the tweet be module
of course so as I mentioned I'm going to
assume that you have Python installed
I won't assume that you have tweet be
installed so if you don't have it
installed what you'll need to do is
access it through pip pip install tweet
pea if you run this command in your
terminal it will go ahead and install
for me I already have it installed so it
says requirement already satisfied so
sorry about that I've forgot to mention
that earlier so back to the code go back
to here let's go ahead and start
importing some of the things that we'll
be making use of that are coming from
the twee' pea library so the first thing
that well import is thuy be streaming
import stream listener this is a class
that's from the Tweety module that will
allow us to listen to the tweets kind of
the firehose of tweets as they as they
come based on certain keywords or
hashtags we'll also need to import
another thing for authentication
so we'll say from TP imports ooofff
handler this class is going to be
responsible for authenticating based on
the credentials that we store it in the
other file for associated with the
Twitter app and then we're going to have
one more thing from tweet P imports
stream and I guess another important
that we required out from tweet P is the
credentials file that we created so
imports Twitter credentials
and again this should be located in the
same folder as this file that we're
ready to currently so the first thing
that I want to do is I just want to
create a class which will allow us to
print the tweets so a very simple thing
and then we'll go back over it and kind
of make it a little bit more robust and
we'll refine what it's doing but simple
first so let's create a class and we'll
call this standard out listener and this
class is going to actually inherit from
stream listener so it's going to inherit
from the stream listener class and the
stream listener class provides methods
that we can directly override so one of
the methods is called on underscore data
class method that takes in a parameter
data and there's another one that we can
also override called on error which also
is cost method and takes a status
variable so what are these functions do
what are they responsible for on data is
an overin method which will take in the
data that is streamed in from the stream
listener so the one that is listening
for tweets and then it's going to print
we can do whatever we want with that
data that tweet so what we're gonna do
just to make it very simple is we're
going to print out the data that we get
and then we're just going to return true
to make sure that everything went well
we will go back and make that a bit more
robust because that's a very simplistic
at the moment on error this is what a
method that we are overriding from the
string listener class that happens if
there's an error that occurs and one
thing we can do again which is just very
simple is we can just print out the
error which is passed in through this
status variable we're just printing it
on it on-screen so if we encounter an
error what will happen is this method
will be triggered and will print the
status message of that error to the
screen so the next thing that we're
going to want to do is just actually
create a method sorry an object from
this standard out listener class that we
just created and then actually get on to
streaming the tweets so this will be in
the main part of the program so we'll
say if name is equal to
made and what will first do is create a
listener object so I want to say
listener is equal to standard out
listener like that so again this is just
an object of the class that we just
created which is inheriting from the
stream listener class and then what
we're going to do is we're going to want
to authenticate so we're going to want
to authenticate using the credentials
that we had stored in the other file so
we're going to create this variable
called auth and we're going to say o
auth handler which is the class that
we're importing from TP which is going
to be responsible for actually
authenticating to our code and we're
going to pass it in the credentials so
we're gonna say Twitter credentials dot
consumer key and Twitter credentials dot
consumer secret so this in order for us
to define this auth object of the auth
handler class it takes these two
arguments that we need to pass in and
then in order for us to complete the
authentication processes we're going to
say off that set access token and this
is a method which is provided from the
OAuth handler class and what this takes
this method also takes two arguments and
that takes the access token and the
access token secret at this point our
application hopefully should be properly
authenticated so we'll create a Twitter
stream based on the so most we'll call
this will create a variable called
stream equal to this Lane which is the
class stream that we imparted above and
we're gonna pass the two things the
authentication token to verify that
we've actually authenticated properly
and then the listener object that we
created and the listener object is just
responsible for how do I deal with the
data the tweets and how do I deal with
the error if I encounter an error one
final thing that we can do is we can
filter the tweets because otherwise if
we just run this stream if we run this
listener it's just going to stream a ton
of tweets at us which might be some of
them might be interesting some of them
might not be let's say we want to stream
tweets that are focused on some keywords
or hash tags or something like that so
what we can do is we could say stream
dots
filter this is a method that is also
provided by the stream class and that
what this takes is a list one of the
things that can take is an optional
parameter of a list which is called
track and in this track list we can
provide it a list of things which if the
Twitter sorry if the tweet contains any
of these lists objects then it will
apply it and it will say I'll add this
to the stream so let's see let's just
add Donald Trump
let's Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama
and let's say Bernie Sanders so just
some politicians in there so we'll
filter tweets based on this list of
keywords so we can go ahead and run
write this to a file and then we can go
ahead and try to see what happens when
we run it so python tweet be streamer
now if we run this we get so let's see a
401 let's check why that happens to be I
think the reason for that was because I
didn't fill in any of the consumer key
consumer secret or anything like that I
just written it from what you saw before
all those things were completely blank
so don't be me don't be an idiot go
ahead and make sure you fill that stuff
in and once you do if you do that
hopefully that should run and things
should start coming down the screen
there so like we see a ton of looks
seemingly garbage just showing up on the
screen here these are tweets
specifically these are let me just kind
of stop this here so if you don't stop
it it'll just keep you know just keep
streaming so this whole blob here this
is one tweet it's not the person didn't
tweet this thing out of course what this
is is it's a JSON formatted dictionary
object and each of the fields in this
braced thing here contains information
about the tweet so this says the tweet
was created today this is today this is
the you know
ID that Twitter associates with this
particular tweet apparently it was a
retweet by this person here here is the
actual text so Donald Trump that's one
of the keywords that we had in the
in the list check so 2019 state of the
unit speech is January thirtieth TV
ratings so yeah there's just some stuff
that he's saying there what what other
content do we have on this thing that's
interesting let's see so it tells you
also about like who retweeted it how
many times been retweeted there's a
whole ton of information in this little
thing here I think even the platform
coordinates possibly of where this was
tweeted from in some cases sometimes
that's not provided but there's a ton of
information in this thing so there's one
suite here and what we're going to be
doing its subsequent videos is actually
going through each of these and seeing
if we can extract anything interesting
any insights from these things and just
kind of have some fun with it so back to
the code so what we have at this point
is just something that prints out tweets
to the screen which is totally fine that
it's proof of concept we've got tweets
coming in but I'm just going to clean
some of this up to make this a bit more
robust so that in subsequent videos
things are just kind of a little bit
more
well robust I guess is the right word so
let's go and create another class which
we'll call let's call this Twitter
streamer so this is going to be a class
that will define for ourselves which
will be responsible for actually
streaming the tweets just makes it a
little bit more concise so we'll call
this stream tweets and this is a class
method so it takes the object of self
I'm kind of thinking ahead here and
assuming that instead of just printing
tweets to the terminal like we saw there
perhaps I want to save tweets to a text
file or a JSON file so that way I can
process them for whatever purpose I see
fit later so I'm going to allow the
ability for us to pass in a name which
will be the file name of the tweets that
will pass in so let's say fetched tweets
final name I'll call that so again
that's just the final name of where we
want to let's say write our tweets to
instead of showing them on the terminal
we can do both but we don't have to and
then I'll also have a hashtag list here
so this will just be the list
of keywords or hashtags we wish to
filter the tweets out by so we're really
just kind of reworking some of the code
that we have that's the proof of concept
into something that's a little bit more
modular so let's go ahead and add a
comment just to make this look a little
nicer
this handles Twitter authentication and
the connection to the Twitter streaming
API so we're going to pretty much just
take this code that we wrote down here
and I think we're just going to let's
just copy that either remove it move
that over here let's go ahead and indent
that so we'll create the listener object
that's all good
authenticate do that so instead of
hard-coding this here I guess what I'm
going to do is I'm going to remove this
and I'm going to put in the hashtag list
that we passed into the function so a
bit more modular so we can just create a
Twitter streamer object instead of doing
that whole business that we had before
in the main part of the code another
thing that I guess I want to do in this
standard out listener class that we
defined is well let's see let's just let
me just add a few more comments here so
I want to add a comment for this class
this class is a class for streaming and
let's say processing live tweets that
looks good and then here let's do
another one this is really this is a
basic listener class that just prints at
this moment anyway just prints received
tweets to standard out so that might
change over time as we make this more
complicated so I guess the first thing
that we'll do is we'll create a
constructor for this thing because what
I want to do is I want to create a
standard about let's enter a class or
object rather and that may be associated
with a filename that these are going to
be writing to so where do we want to
store the tweets so I'm gonna say
fetched tweets file name
as a class variable so I'm going to say
self dot fetch tweets file name is equal
to fetched tweets file name so this odd
data method is a little bit I could use
a little bit of something to make it a
little bit better at dealing with
possible errors so I'm going to have a
try except statement here so I'm going
to say try
let's save print data and then actually
I'm not going to put anything well okay
let's say let's say that we also want to
write this stuff to a file too right so
we've already created this file name
that we've defined the constructor of
this class let's say with open self dot
fetched tweets file name and will append
because we keep once we want to
continually add the tweets as we stream
them from the API stf little writes the
data so if you have that right data so
if you don't want to print it out and
also write it you can get rid of that
print statement but it's totally up to
you if that what okay will return true
and then we'll have it accept case here
so except will say base exception and
then if that exception is hit we'll say
print error on on data just to make sure
that we know if the method that we are
in and then let's go ahead and print out
let's print out the actual error message
so we'll print out the string of E and
then we'll return true okay so I think
that's okay the error on error message I
think is alright for now and then okay
so now we have to change a little bit
here in this main function so let's go
ahead and use our new class to do pretty
much what we did before but just make it
a little bit more nice and modular so
what we'll do is we'll create a hashtag
list here well I guess create it as
let's say Donald Trump Hillary Clinton
Barack Obama and Bernie Sanders and
let's see so we could also say let's
define our fetch tweets file name as
let's just call it tweets JSON so again
as we saw from the output of the
terminal those tweets the braced objects
are they can be formatted as JSON it's a
little bit easier for us to deal with
that format if we want to read linen
later you could put that txt there
that's totally fine but I'm just
changing the extension to JSON it's not
necessary if you don't want to do that
okay so now let's define a Twitter
streamer object so I'll say Twitter
streamer is equal to Twitter streamer
and then we'll say Twitter streamer
there it is
dot stream tweets which is the method
that we created up above and we'll send
it takes two things the file name that
we want to write to and then also the
list of keywords that we're looking for
so that just made that a little bit more
concise and everything a little bit more
modular and that will kind of get us
started on this whole stream of tweets
lean
chin up some of the code that we wrote
in part one so I'll be touching up some
code and we'll be focusing on the notion
of page nation and also the cursor
object in Twitter and specifically the
tweet P library so we'll be making use
of that to do things like accessing our
own tweets on our timeline accessing
user tweets from a specific user that we
might want to analyze tweets from also
getting followers or friends from
certain users and other things like that
so we've been making use of the cursor
class int we P to do that so the first
item on the board is to clean up a few
things that we did in part one just to
make things a little bit more
streamlined and modular before we do
that I do want to import two things here
at the top which will be making use of
in this video one of them is called API
so from sweepy import api the other is
called cursor so from tweet p import
cursor so once we have those we're ready
to make some changes so the first thing
I want to do is I want to I think change
the name of this Twitter stream listener
class so before I guess the initial idea
of this class was just to print out the
tweet but this class is doing a little
bit more than that it's also writing it
to a file standard out listener it's
probably not the best name for this
class since it can do a little bit more
than just print it out to the screen
let's call that something a little bit
more general let's just call it Twitter
listener which would mean we'll also
have to change the reference to that
class over here we make an object called
listener so the next thing that I want
to do is I thought that authenticating
here in this stream tweets function is
fine but I thought I would abstract this
functionality into its own class so that
way we can authenticate for other
purposes that we may have indeed we'll
have those other purposes in this video
so I'm going to create another class up
here which will be for authentication so
I'm going to call this let's say Twitter
Authenticator and we'll call the class
Twitter Authenticator and what we'll do
in this class is I'm just at this moment
going to have a function which will do
precisely what these two lines do I just
want to extract extrapolate that into
this class so
what we're going to do is we're going to
define a function called authenticate
Twitter app it's class method so it'll
take self as a parameter and then what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
essentially lift these two things here
and then move them into this function
over here and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to return the auth object
that I create in this in this function
so the plan is in this Twitter streamer
class before we had this actual these
two lines creating the authentication
what we're gonna do now is we're just
going to create instantiate an object of
the Authenticator class here in the
constructor and then use that object
rights where we had the previous code so
let me actually just write that out
because maybe that's a little bit more
clear
so we'll say self dot Twitter
Authenticator this will be the class
object of the Authenticator class and
then what we'll do here is we'll just
say auth is equal to self dot Twitter
Authenticator dot authenticate Twitter
app and that will go ahead and do the
same thing that those two lines did but
we've just kind of lifted that
functionality into a class of its own to
make it a bit more modular so I think
that's one of the changes I wanted to
make let's just go ahead and write this
and go ahead and run it to make sure
that we didn't break anything so it
looks like that's streaming tweets just
as it was before seems like that worked
out ok the next thing I want to mention
that I didn't before that I thought
would be worthwhile to point out is this
on error method now I did touch on this
in part 1 of the video and I did say
that if you encounter an error while
you're streaming tweets this method will
be triggered and in this case what we're
doing here is we're printing the status
message of the error but we might want
to do a little bit more checking here
namely Twitter the Tweety API imposes
these things most specifically the
Twitter API imposes these things called
rates of limits and essentially if
you're throttling the Twitter API trying
to get all this information and Twitter
doesn't like that it might try to stop
you from abusing the system let's say so
basically if Twitter thinks that you're
doing that it's going to give you an
error message which is going to be a 4
to 0 for 20
message and that's going to be like hey
if you keep doing this that will
essentially kick you you basically the
first time you get this message there's
a window of time where you have to wait
to access the tweets again and if you
keep accessing tweets and you ignore
those messages that window of time
increases exponentially so you can lock
yourself out of accesses information so
it's worthwhile to check that the status
message the error code that you're
receiving is is not in this form so what
we want to do is we want to say if the
status is equal to this error code which
is in this case for 20 we want to just
return false outright that's it we just
want to kill the connection so that way
we don't you know accidentally boot
ourselves from accessing information on
Twitter and I'll just put in a comment
here just so if you're looking at this
later and you forget what this is for
returning false data method in case
basically in case rates limit is occurs
let's say okay so that is I think all of
the changes let me just get rid of that
extra space there and that is that okay
great now we can start into actually
making use of the cursor module that we
imported there the cursor class and also
essentially figure out how to use that
to extract timeline tweets on your own
timeline or friends timeline or things
of that nature so to do that what we're
gonna do is we're going to create
another class and we'll call this let's
call this class Twitter client so it'll
be class Twitter clients and what we'll
do here is we will make use well I guess
let's first create a constructor object
create constructor method and so it's
just going to take self at the moment
and what we'll do is we will create an
Authenticator object so this is why we
created the Authenticator class so we'll
say self dot auth is equal to Twitter
Authenticator authenticate Twitter app
so this is just going to be the auth
object so that way we can properly
authenticate to
communicate with the Twitter API and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to define another class variable
which we'll call it Twitter clients and
this is going to be equal to API which
as you'll notice is one of the two
things that we imported from tweet P in
this video and it will pass it in the
authentication credentials so that way
that is authenticated so we're going to
make use of that in the following
functions that we'll write in this class
and actually what I'm gonna do here is
I'm just going to comment these things
out and then we're going to instantiate
an object with the Twitter client class
and see what we can do with this so okay
so let's start off with a function that
will allow us to get tweets so we're
gonna call this function
I guess gets tweets and we're going to
pass in the parameter self since this is
a class method and then we're also going
to pass in another argument here which
is called num tweets and this will allow
us to determine how many tweets we want
to actually show or how many tweets we
actually want to extract so we're going
to first do this we're going to define a
list which is called let's say we'll say
tweets tweets is equal to an empty list
what we're gonna do is loop through a
certain number of tweets and then for
each one we do we're going to store that
in the list and return that list to the
user so we'll say for tweet and cursor
self dot Twitter client user timeline so
I'll explain these things as I go dot
items num tweets let's actually break
this down what I just wrote here so we
import a cursor this is a class that
will allow us to essentially do or about
to do which is get the user timeline
tweets so I should actually call this
let's say get user timeline tweets and
yeah let's keep it like that so
basically what I'm doing is I'm saying
okay that client object that we created
here in the in the constructor there's a
there's a method for every object
derived from this API class that has
this user of timeline functionality and
that allows you specifying a user to get
the tweets off that users timeline so we
haven't specified a user and in that
if you don't specify user just defaults
to you so if that argument is none which
it is by default then it will just get
your own timeline tweets and then
there's a parameter for the cursor
object called items and that will tell
this thing how many tweets to actually
get from the timeline so we can specify
that as an argument sent in this
function here so what we'll do in this
loop we're a little bit through every
tweet that this cursor object provides
to us and what we can do is we can say
tweet dot append yeah sweets
sorry tweets dot append to tweets is the
list that we're storing these things in
dot append tweet and then we can just
return the tweets list and that can be
that will now consist of a list of all
of the user timeline tweets so let's go
ahead and stand you a client object and
see if that works for our own timeline
so going down to the bottom here what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
create first like I mentioned a Twitter
clients object so Twitter client is
equal to Twitter clients like that and
then what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to print the function that we just
created so Twitter client dot get user
timeline tweets and that takes an
argument that argument is the number of
tweets to get in this case I'll say
let's say five so let's make sure that
works let's save that and run it so
we'll see what tweets are on my timeline
so it's got quite a few so remember
these tweets come in these big blobs so
actually to make this a little bit more
readable I'm going to replace that
number with just one so I just want to
first clear my screen to make it a
little bit easier to read and then
actually go and run this again this will
only get one tweet this whole thing is
one tweet and basically this is if I go
to let's see if I can find some
information about this tweet that will
distinguish it then we'll go to my
Twitter profile to verify this actually
got the correct tweet so I see something
about sam harris org let's see is there
anything else here well let's actually
go to my Twitter yeah so it looks like a
lot on
so okay yeah let's verify that this is
actually the most recent tweet on my
timeline has something to do with Sam
Harris so I have my Twitter page up here
this is my personal Twitter page feel
free to follow me if you like no
obligation anyway yeah so there-there we
see this is the most recent tweet that i
retweeted from sam harris and it's of
the late great Christopher Hitchens who
if you're not a fan of shame on you he's
a really interesting guy and I encourage
you to read about him if you don't know
who he is so this isn't a political
channel but he's amazing anyway so
that's that so yeah so we've
successfully obtained the the most
recent tweet on my timeline great now
what if we want to do that for a
specific user so if we want to do this
for someone other than myself how do we
do that well we can modify our function
a little bit to allow us to specify that
information so let's go ahead and do
that so what we're gonna do is we're
going to create another variable here
which we'll call self dot Twitter user
is equal to Twitter user we have a
defined Twitter user yet we're going to
pass that in here as an argument so
basically what we'll do is we'll
instantiate an object a Twitter client
object and what we want to do is we want
to allow the the person who is using
this code to specify a user that they
can get the timeline tweets from but
actually what we're gonna want to do is
we're going to put in a default argument
of none so if you haven't seen this type
of syntax before if you have you know
like a function like this with an
argument that has equal none or equal
anything this is a default argument and
if nothing is specified here for Twitter
user it just defaults to none and
remember in our case none if you don't
specify a Twitter user it will just go
to your own timeline so we want to
specify a user so we will be doing that
so the way that we tell the tweet be API
that we've specified a user is in this
cursor function here this method will
say ID is equal to self dot Twitter user
so that will do that so
now that will actually get the user type
light tweets for whatever user we
specify so let's go ahead and give that
a run to verify that actually worked so
the way that we're going to do that
remember is instantiate the Twitter
client object based on who we want to
get the timeline tweets from so in this
case I'm going to specify based on a
user PyCon what is PyCon how do I know
that's PyCon let's go back here
soap icon if you're not aware is a
conference that folks focuses on the
Python programming language and if
you're not familiar with it you should
check it out again also on YouTube all
the talks are available there lots of
really interesting talks and topics I
highly suggest you check it out so
anyway this is the user this is the
tweets that we want to obtain the
timeline or the home tweets from and the
way that I got PyCon was I just followed
the what what followed the @ symbol here
so this is the name of the user of which
we wish to extract the tweets from so
let me just minimize that we've
specified that it spike on will also get
just one tweet from this user so let's
go ahead and write that and run it and
see what we get so let's see well what
did we get here so we get a lot of stuff
let's just get some identifying
information here let's see so is there a
text field so this is a text field this
is generally will it actually the next
video what we'll do is we'll break down
what we're looking at here there's a lot
of information here in this tweet it's
not just the text of the tweet it's the
you know ID information the user
information the retweet information all
those other stuff so we'll break down
precisely what is going on here but
there's a field in this mess which is
called text and this is actually the
text of the tweet so it says all early
bird registrations have been claimed but
it's still far from too late to register
for PyCon u.s. 2018 so let's verify that
this tweet is actually on the timeline
so if we go here we see that this is the
most recent tweet that we extracted
indeed all early bird registration had
been claimed but it's too far from too
late to register for pi cloud u.s. 2018
cool so we're we have successfully
extracted a flight tweet from another
user
so I'm going to mention a couple of
other functions which are related but
different to the user type light tweets
and they all kind of have a similar form
so I'm just going to I guess quickly
write those down just so you can have
access to them you can play with them
the form of all these functions is
pretty much the same so if you
understand how this one works
the other ones that I'm going to write
which are just two other ones should be
pretty similar so the other one that we
can do is we can get Fred lists so this
also will be a class method we can also
determine how many friends we get by a
parameter here that we'll set so this
again just like we did before we're
going to define it empty for a list
which will store all of the friends for
a given user in this case I'm not going
to specify the user just because I guess
it's not really necessary to get the
concept of how this thing works so I'm
going to define a loop for friend and
cursor self dot Twitter client dot
friends that items dumb friends so just
to very briefly go over this you should
see a similar type of idea on line 18 as
you do on line 25
so we're looping over Twitter client dot
friends in this case not use your time
line and then we're getting a certain
number of friends of that user based on
the argument that we passed into the
function and then what we're gonna want
to do as we loop through is we could say
friend list dot append friend and then
we can just return the friend list so
similar concept to what we saw above
just a hammer that pattern or to give
you another instance of that pattern
that we saw here we can also get the
let's call it get timeline let's see
let's we can get home timeline let's
call it that gets home
timeline tweets so these are you know
you have your own tweets that you've
tweeted out yourself the home line or
the home line oh my goodness that the
home timeline tweets those are the ones
that if you go to your Twitter page on
the home page you will see all the
people that you follow and everything
like that so the top tweets there
and in following you know from there are
the whole timeline tweets and that's we
can also extract those for a given user
as well so the pattern there is similar
as well so we'll say self num tweets
like that we'll say let's say home
timeline tweets is the list that will
store them in for tweets in cursor self
dot Twitter client so this should look
pretty familiar and we'll say dot will
say home oops
client home timeline tweets are just
home timeline dot items and then we'll
pass in the number of tweets we wished
you would get from our home timeline or
any users home timeline that we happen
to specify and then we'll say home
timeline tweets dot append tweet and
then we'll return that as well so these
functions all kind of have a similar
flavor to them the way that they work
this get user timeline sorry about that
this gate user timeline here also allows
us to specify the ID of the user and
actually we can very quickly do that
here as well just by saying ID is equal
to self dot Twitter user and we can also
add that onto this one as well so I D is
equal to self dot twitter twitter user
so if you want more information about
these API calls I will also link in the
description to this API reference page
which is associated with the tweet be
documentation so if you want more
information on some of these other
things that we maybe didn't have so much
time to go into so you can see there's
the home timeline function there's also
other parameters that you might be
interested in instead of getting the
number of tweets perhaps you want to get
certain number of pages from a user or
from your own timeline there's also some
other ones so we saw user timeline you
can get retweets of me statuses update
statuses you can update your status via
the Tweety API if you wish to do so
destroy status I mean there's a ton of
things here and I'm just going to kind
of let your
go and leave you this page and if you
want to experiment with these things
this is very well documented and I
suggest that you do that
we're going to be analyzing some tweets
well we're going to really set up the
infrastructure first so we can take some
tweets and then analyze them using
pandas and numpy so in order for us to
proceed with the remaining part of this
video both of those modules need to be
installed so I'm just going to go ahead
and open up a separate tab here and if
you don't already have numpy and pandas
installed then you'll need to run the
following command in the terminal let me
just make this a little bit bigger so if
you run pip install pandas this is going
to essentially give us the content that
will allow us to store the tweets and
the corresponding things that we extract
from those tweets into something called
a data frame this will allow us to pass
this around maybe make a graph out of it
so you'll need this in order to store
the content into these data frames the
other thing that we'll need is also
numpy numpy is just a general-purpose
numerical library for python that does a
lot of things we'll only be using it for
very small you know 0.001 percent of its
functionality in this video but you're
gonna need it nonetheless so I'm gonna
say install numpy so you'll notice by
the way that I tried to install pandas
it said I already have it which is fine
you might see the message as well if you
already have pan is installed I'm gonna
see a similar message here for a numpy
as well it says that I already have it
installed on my machine so I'm good to
go so I'm gonna close that out and then
I'm going to go back to the file that
we've been working with and again I will
say this at the end of the video but all
the code will be available on my github
I'm just continuing on from part two of
this series and just working from that
code so you can work along with me or
you can download the completed code once
it's been uploaded with this video as
well what if we prefer so I'm gonna go
ahead and import both pandas and numpy
so I'm just gonna say import numpy as NP
and then also import pandas as PD so
this is just a general convention this
will allow us to refer to anything from
the numpy library by just using the dot
operator so we can say num MP dot the
name of a function that's provided from
numpy similarly for pandas anytime we
want to access a function from pandas we
can just say and I should say as here as
PD so we can just say PD dot
name of a function that comes from the
module pandas that should do it so the
next thing that I want to do is I want
to add a function in this Twitter client
class that's going to allow us to
essentially just get directly this
Twitter client API so we can interface
with this API and we can essentially
extract data from the tweets that we get
so I'm going to create another function
in this Twitter client class let's just
go ahead and call it get Twitter client
API it's gonna take self since it's a
member of this class and then really all
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
return the variable that we defined up
here so I'm just going to say return
self dot Twitter client and that's it so
that's the only thing I want to add in
this class let's go down to the bottom
of the file so in the bottom of the file
we have this this content from previous
videos I'm just going to go ahead and
remove all this stuff within the main
portion of this file and I'm going to
create another class which is going to
be responsible for analyzing the tweets
that we extract from Twitter so I'm
going to call this class let's call it
let's call it tweet analyzers so we'll
say tweets analyzer and this is just
going to be a class we'll go ahead and
put in a comment here to briefly
describe what this class is supposed to
be doing let's say functionality for
analyzing and categorizing content from
tweets something like that okay so
that's a brief description of that class
so we'll eventually go it and fill this
in let me go down to the main portion of
the file here and let's just go ahead
and create a Twitter client and then use
that function that we created before to
allow us to get the API so we can
interface with that because that's what
we're going to be using to get the
tweets before we analyze them so I'm
gonna say Twitter clients which is a
variable I'm going to be defining that
equal to the Twitter client class and
then I'm just going to go ahead and call
the function that we just created I'm
going to say API is equal to Twitter
clients dot get Twitter client API which
is what we called it so now API is a
variable that has the Twitter client
object that we created in that class so
now what I want to do is I also want to
start streaming some tweets so let's go
ahead and define a variable
that will just call tweets and this is
going to be something that we can obtain
from the client that we just created
there so I'm going to say API dot user
underscore timeline so user timeline is
a function that is provided from the
Twitter client API so it's not a
function that we've written this user
timeline it's not a function that we've
written it's a function from the Twitter
client so just to be clear on that so
this function will allow us to specify a
number of things one thing we can
specify is the user that we want to
extract tweets from and another thing
that we can also specify in this
function is how many tweets we want to
extract from that user so I guess just
for the sake of example let's go ahead
and say that the screen name which is
how we specify the user is equal to some
Twitter user in this case I'm going to
be using Donald Trump as an example
because I guess he's you know someone
that's well known on Twitter so real
Donald Trump is his Twitter handle so
I'm just going to use that as the
variable screen name that we're passing
into this function that's again given to
us by the Twitter client API and then we
can also specify how many tweets we want
to extract from his page by saying count
which is a variable again you can
consult the documentation for what the
variables should be called in these
functions you can't just call screen
name anything you can't just call count
anything these are variables that are
specified from the documentation that we
can hard code values to and that's what
we're doing now as we call this function
so count will specify how many tweets we
want to grab from in this case real
Donald 12 Trump let's just say 20 and
then what we can do is we can let's just
go ahead and just make sure this works
and say print tweets so with any luck
what this is gonna do is it's gonna go
to the real Donald Trump stream the most
recent 20 tweets and then we'll print
that content out on the screen so I'm
just going to clear the terminal I'm
gonna say Python this is called
analyzing Twitter data which is the file
that we're in and I'm just going to
write that so we see here that we've got
so I actually had to restore that
because I believe I was streaming or I
was running a file from another
directory with the same name so that was
my fault
so again just going back to clearing the
terminal and then running this file
which is in the directory that we're in
we run this we get this content here
which we can see is coming from Donald
Trump's Twitter page so you can see that
a few key indicators here from just the
text see Donald J Trump so there's a
couple of basically this is just one big
tweet which has a number of features for
a tweet which are specified in the JSON
format and we can extract parts of that
if we want to analyze whatever part that
we might be interested in so in this
video what we're going to be doing is
just kind of honing in on a few key
aspects of what content we can extract
from a single tweet and then just
putting that into a data frame so we've
got this tweet we know that it works
we're streaming tweets from Donald
Trump's Twitter page and now what we can
do is we can go ahead and create a data
frame which is going to store that
content and just going to allow us to
neatly organize that and also to process
it for further data analysis later so
we're going to make use of this tweet
analyzer class which we've created up
here and also the numpy and pandas
modules that we imported so the first
thing that I want to do is I want to
create a function in this tweet analyzer
class let's call it tweets to data frame
so it's just going to take the tweets
that we've gotten here which is just
this big JSON string and then convert it
to a data frame so in this it'll take
self it's a member of the class and it
will also take the tweets that we want
to convert to a data frame so what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to create
the data frame object and I'm going to
say D F which is going to be the data
frame is equal to PPD data frame so this
is a function that's provided to us from
pandas this will allow us to create a
data frame based on some content that we
feed it and then what we can do is we
can specify the data that we want to
make the data frame out of so we can say
data is equal to and what we're going to
want to do in this is give it a list and
this list is going to be created from
the tweets that we feed in to this
function so I'm gonna say this is equal
to the text of the tweet which we can
extract by essentially saying tweet text
for this tweet that we're going to do
I'm just going to write out the loop and
then I'm gonna explain what precisely
this loop does for tweet in tweets so
just to kind of unpack what's going on
here
we've specified this variable that we're
feeding into the data frame function and
we're creating a list and we're Lu
through every single tweet in this
tweets thing that we're feeding in here
and basically what we're doing is that
we want to extract the text from each of
those tweets so we're creating a list
where each object in that list is the
text of each of the tweets so that's
what this data list is corresponding to
and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna specify the column for which just
to specify where these are going to live
in the data frame so I'm just going to
give the column a name so columns is
equal to let's say tweets just to
specify kind of what we're storing in
this column and then I'm just going to
go ahead and return the data frame that
we've created here so down here we have
our tweets and then what I'm going to do
is we're going to go ahead and say data
frame is equal to well I guess before we
do that we need to create a tweet
analyzer object for the class we've
created so let's call it tweet analyzer
let's have this be equal to the tweet
analyzer class so it's we're creating an
object of this class and then we can go
ahead and say now that we've specified
that data frame is equal to tweet
analyzer dot tweets to data frame and
then we'll feed in the tweets that we've
got from this line up here so we've
gotten our tweets from using the client
API and then what we're doing here is
we're creating a data frame object which
again is being returned from this
function and then we're setting that
equal to what this function is doing
which is essentially taking the tweets
we've gotten converting that into a data
frame and it's storing that data frame
in DF here so just to see what we've got
we can go ahead and say prints DF head
and this is just going to print out the
first couple elements in this case the
first 10 elements of the data frame that
we've created so I'm going to write that
I'm going to clear the terminal and then
we're gonna say Python analyzing Twitter
data if we do this we get very nicely
formatted information here so each of
these are the first 10 objects of this
data frame that we've created and you
can see the tweet text of each of these
is stored under this heading tweets so
that's kind of cool
so we can also extract other pieces of
information from each of the tweets so
let's actually just I'm going to comment
I'm gonna comment this out for now and
what we can do is we can figure out what
other attributes of these tweets we can
extract data from so if I save prints dr
of tweets of zero what I'm essentially
doing is I'm printing out the
essentially the information that we can
extract from just the first tweet so
this is going to show us what types of
pieces of information we can extract
from every tweet
I'm just confining my space to just
looking at the first tweet and seeing
what objects we can extract from this
tweet happen to be so I'm gonna go ahead
and write that and run this thing so if
we run this we see all of the it's
essentially a list of all of the
possible things that we can ask of this
tweet we can ask the user we can ask the
text which we saw we can ask how many
retweets there are we can ask the how
many likes they're our favorite count so
we can ask where this tweet actually
came from the ID a whole bunch of things
and so what we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to figure out how to
extract this information from each
individual tweet put that information
into our data frame and then kind of
build on this so not only do we have the
text for each of the tweets but we've
also got maybe the ID the light count
things like that so that's what we want
to do so I'm just going to go ahead and
comment this out that's just supposed to
kind of illustrate what things we can
extract so now what we can do is we can
also kind of be a little bit more
granular I guess for another sake of
example let me print out tweets of 0.9 D
so the way that we access let's say the
ID of tweet 0 in this list we've
extracted we can just use the dot ID
method here to allow us to extract what
the ID of that particular tweet is so
I'm going to write that run this here
and we see that if we run this this is
the ID that corresponds to the tweet
that we've we've gotten there we can
also say let's just say retweet count
which is another one of the things that
we can ask about this tweet we run that
we can get how many let's see so maybe
it's not spelled correctly here let me
just make sure that I spelled out try
that again so this is going to give us
how many times this particular tweet
tweet zero and that list was retweeted
it's a total of 5,000 3 294 times so
that's just some information about how
we can extract this content and there's
of course many different possibilities
for the type of directions that you go
with this information
let's just go back up to our function
here and then kind of build on this data
frame to allow us to continually add to
it so we can kind of get get all of this
information in a more helpful context
for us to process it so let's go ahead
and say that we want to in addition to
storing the text of the tweet let's say
that we also want to store the ID so we
can say DF ID so we're essentially
creating a column in our data frame with
the heading ID and we can set this equal
to something so we're going to
essentially feed it in a numpy array
which is going to be essentially a list
of the content that we're after for each
of the tweets so in this case we're
interested in the ID of each of the
tweets so we're going to want to loop
through every single one of the tweets
in the tweets that were given and then
extract the ID from that so I'm gonna
say NP array so this is just a numpy
array object that we're creating here
and this is basically what the data
frame we're creating a data frame column
based on this array and what we're
converting to an array is a list so the
list that we're going to be feeding into
this is similar to what we saw above so
we can say tweet dot ID so that's again
how we extracted the ID for a specific
tweet as we saw down here below we
wanted to extract the retweet count or
the ID we did tweet zero or whatever ID
that corresponds to in our list of
tweets dot aidid retweet count whatever
we happen to be interested in so we're
doing the ID here so what we're doing is
we want to extract that information kind
of in a similar format to what we saw up
here
so for tweets in tweets so again what
we're doing is we take the tweets that
we've gotten in from this function we're
looping through each and every single
one of those in that list and then we're
saying give me the ID of that particular
tweet store it and array convert that
array to an umpire array and then create
a column in this data frame with a
heading ID based on every single one of
those right so the lot going on in that
one line so now that we have that let's
just go ahead and make sure that we have
the data frame update appropriately so
we're gonna uncomment this line down
here that creates the data frame based
on our function that we have part of our
class and then let's just go ahead and
right the thing that we had before which
was Prince D F dot head and let's just
see what the first elements look like so
we'll write that and then we'll give
this a run so if we run this we see that
not only do we have our tweets for each
of the columns here but we refer each of
the rows here rather we also have the ID
as well so the corresponding ID for this
tweet is stored right here corresponding
ID for this tweet here right there so on
and so forth so basically we're just
going to keep extracting some
information that might be useful and
it's going to have a very similar
pattern to this line so I'm just going
to go ahead and copy this line a couple
times and we're gonna see what other
information we can extract and again if
you want to see any of the other types
of pieces of information that you could
extract from a given tweet you can just
uncomment this to see what those
attributes are so we're just going to go
through this and come show some other
examples so let's say I want to figure
out what the length of a tweet is so I
want to figure out how how long a given
tweet is for one reason or another so
what I can do is same format I want to
loop through all the tweets in the
tweets that we've been given in this
function but instead of the ID I want to
analyze the text and specifically I want
to analyze the length of that text right
so I'm going through each of the tweets
and I'm saying figure out what each of
the lengths of the tweets are sorry I
keep on doing something here we just put
this here right okay so there so I'm
extracting the length of each of the
tweets as we loop through them and I'm
storing that in this list
converting it to an umpire array and
then creating a column called Len which
is going to store that information so
maybe another attribute that we care
about is the date that the tweet was
posted so same sort of concept here the
way that we can extract that information
again which we can figure out by
uncommenting this line here and seeing
what the attributes are you can also
consult the documentation by the way to
see if it's not clear based on the name
as to what those things correspond to
you can see what a more elaborate
definition of each of those attributes
in the documentation so if you're not
sure you can get soul thought so for us
to get to get the date here we can say
created dot created at so this is going
to give us the
that particular tweet was created at
same process there let's say that we
also want to do this source so this is
going to allow us to determine where the
tweet is coming from was from an iPhone
was from an Android desktop PC and the
way that we can get that information is
by saying dot source let's say we also
want to do the number of likes so in
that case what we're going to be doing
is doing the favorite count favorite
underscore count and then let's do one
more let's say that we also want to
figure out how many retweets there were
for a given tweet so what we can do
there is instead of favorite count as we
saw down below we can just do retweet
count so now we've got all of these new
columns in our data frame that we've
created here and they're being added to
the data frame that we're returning here
and then when we create the data frame
object here from the tweets we're given
we should be able to see a whole bunch
of new columns that we've created from
this function let's just go ahead and
write that let's clear the terminal and
then let's just make sure that we see
all of that information so I'll run this
here and it looks like that worked so we
have the text of each of the tweets the
corresponding IDs the length so the
number of characters in each of the
tweets the date on which the tweets were
posted where it's coming from so Donald
Trump likes to post from an iPhone how
many likes each of the tweets got so
this one got and particularly like the
most likes out of any of these most
recent tweets and then how many retweets
each of these got as well so that's just
kind of a bird's-eye view of the type of
information that you can extract from
each of these tweets of course the
possibilities are somewhat limitless in
terms of what you can take away from
that in terms of what you can actually
what insights you can derive from that
so this is just kind of setting out the
scaffolding and we'll continue to work
with the scaffolding that we're setting
up here and continue to tweak at it and
see what we can see what we can do
so we created a data frame with the ID
length of a tweet the date that that
tweet was created where that tweet came
from like an iPhone how many likes that
got retweets so on so we've kind of got
this data frame now of every single
tweet that we can get from some user for
some amount of tweets and we can now
take this data and try to visualize it
in some way we're going to be doing some
very simple time series graphs based on
the data that we've already stored and
created in this data frame so one thing
I guess I first want to do just for
consistency's sake is just change this
to a lowercase T doesn't really make any
difference you can keep it uppercase but
I guess I just but the dancing so I just
want to make sure that everything is
consistent okay so now that we've got
all of this let's go down here I'm gonna
get rid of these comments and lines
we've got our data frame being created
I'm also going to get rid of this
showing the head of the data frames
since we already know what that looks
like so let's just before we actually
get to plotting let's just see what we
can do from the data frame that we have
so far to see what types of insights we
can derive with without even actually
graphing anything so for instance that
there's a number of things you can do
here there's you know countless things
that you can analyze we'll just go over
a couple of them and then from there
we'll we'll look at how we can plot some
things and again that's also relatively
endless as well so this is by no means
extensive this is just kind of dipping
your toes into the water of what you can
extract from this type of data so one
thing we can get from our data frames
that we've already got is let's just say
that we want to maybe within the data
frame we have a want to figure out what
is the average length of all the tweets
that we have in our data frame so we
here collect 20 tweets and we want to
figure out okay what is the average
length of all of those 20 tweets and of
course we can change this count from 20
to 200 or 400 or whatever we care about
so let's just write in a comment here
which is gets average length over all
tweets and now that we've stored
everything in this data frame it's going
to make it really easy for us to just
manipulate the data that's already
present in that data frame and then just
get this answer and the way that we can
do that is by manipulating the mean
function in numpy which is just going to
be something that we're going to run
a list in the data frame so let me show
you what I mean by that I'm just going
to print out the result that comes from
running the mean function so I'm gonna
say M PI or MP dot mean it's a little
bit of a lag here since sometimes the
autocomplete can be annoying then so
anyway I'm calling the mean function and
what am i calling the mean function on I
want to figure out the mean of the
length of the tweets so I'm saying DF
length so basically what I'm doing there
is DF length is going to return a list
it's going to return a list of all of
the lengths of all of the 20 tweets in
this case and then we're going to be
running the meed function which is
provided to us from numpy on that list
and then we're going to get a single
number which we're printing out to the
screen so that's what is going on in
this line I'm just going to go ahead and
write that clear the terminal and then
we can go ahead and say python this is
called visualizing Twitter data pie and
we get here that the average length is
120 2.2 characters per per tweet in this
in this size so we can of course
increase that to let's say like maybe an
on a 200 tweets
let's see how that changes when we get a
larger sample of data so it actually
doesn't change terribly much and it's
only gone up a little bit so that's kind
of interesting so I'm gonna bring that
back down to 20 another thing we can ask
is let's say we want to figure out what
is the tweet that received the most
likes in the sample that we've gotten so
we can say get the number of likes for
the most liked tweet so what is what is
the tweet that received the most like or
specifically how many likes to the most
like to tweet get so we can also do
something pretty similar here I'm just
going to copy this line put it here and
instead of taking the mean over a list
what I want to do is take the max
because what we want to do is we want to
figure out the maximum number of likes
that is from the likes column in our
data frame so the likes column stored
all the number of likes for every given
tweet I'm taking the max of that list
using the numpy max function and then
I'm printing that out to the screen so
again we can write that save it run it
see what we get so the maximum number of
likes it looks like over those 20 tweets
was something like 120 1862 so again
maybe I'm just
I want to see how this scales if we
increase the number of tweets from 20 to
200 and it looks like it's gone up by a
factor of two from one hundred twenty
one thousand to three hundred and thirty
two thousand so that's interesting one
more so let's say that we want to do a
very similar thing or instead of getting
the number of likes we want to get the
number of retweets so get the number of
let's say retweets for the most let's
say retweeted retweeted tweet and so
that would be the same exact syntax the
only thing that I'm changing here is the
operation on which I'm performing the
max function on so instead of performing
unlike so I'm going to be performing it
on the retweets column of the data frame
and then printing that out to the screen
so let's go ahead and write that and
then run it so we get so the maximum
number of retweets is 107 thousand so
that's interesting as well so of course
these are just printing out in the
numbers to the screen it's very minimal
in terms of what we're actually doing
with the data there's endless
possibilities for what you can actually
do and extract from these sorts of
insights that we're deriving from this
data so all right so now let's move on
to plotting some time series data and
I'm just going to put in a comment here
to distinguish what we're going to do
from what we previously did time series
and let's say hypothetically that we
want to do is we want to create a time
series plot that's going to show us the
number of let's say likes that Donald
Trump received on any given day over the
course of some days which we can extract
from you know some given count here so
we extract let's say two hundred tweets
maybe that's over you know raged over
some number of days and then for every
one of those days Donald Trump got a
certain number of likes we want to plot
that number of likes that he got on a
given day and then just plot that for
every given day over this time series of
dates okay so that's the general idea of
what we want to show so let's create a
variable which we'll call it time likes
this is going to be equal to a panda's
series object so we're essentially
creating a serious object so we can
eventually plot this as a time series so
I'm gonna say this is equal to PD series
and then this takes two things the data
so there's a data frame that we want to
feed it
which is going to be tough values so
this is PD data frame of likes so we
want to actually get in the number of
likes there there should be in quotes
likes so we're getting the values of the
each of the likes so every day there's
going to be a certain number of likes
that are given and we're extracting the
values from that and then oops and then
what we also want to receive in this
time series function is the index and
the index is essentially the x-axis so
what we're plotting and then for each
what we want to do is for each day show
the number of likes so the number of
likes is kind of the y-axis the date is
the time series itself the number of
days so we're going to set the index is
equal to the data frame of the date
which is something that we've already
extracted from from before from our data
frame so this is our time series object
we've created from pandas and now that's
ready for us to actually just go ahead
and plot that so what we can do is we
could say time underscore likes dot plot
and what we can do is we can we can feed
this a few arguments I'm going to be
feeding this plot function two arguments
basically just the size of the figure
which specifies how big this graph is
going to be and then also let's say the
color so this is going to be the color
of the line that's plotted throughout
the days for every given day so I'm
gonna say fig size is equal to I'm just
gonna say 16 comma 4 that's just the XY
axis of the image that we're gonna see
and then also the color which we can put
as red so the function takes in a string
in this case it's just a single
character that corresponds to a given
color and you can consult the
documentation for what other parameters
this this can take and what valid
arguments these parameters can take as
well so I'm just gonna hard coding those
two and you can leave those blank if you
want to it's not necessary to put them
in there but sometimes you might want to
tweak the graphs in some specific way so
then what we do once we've kind of
created our data that we're going to
plot and once we've created our plot
that we're going to show we actually
need to show the plot so we're going to
say
PLT dot show now this PLT is
something that we need to actually
import from matplotlib which is going to
allow us to show the plots that we've
created so I'm going to go up to the top
of my file and I'm going to make sure
that I have matplotlib important so
we'll just say it for import I'm going
to say let's say from map plot actually
know what I'll do is import sorry about
that pot live dot pie plot as PLT so
basically I'm importing this library
specifically the matplotlib pie plot and
i'm importing it as p LT so this will
hopefully show up eventually sometimes
the autocomplete and vim can take a
little while and collide behind a little
bit there we go so anyway so I'm
importing the map plot library
specifically from that I'm importing PI
plot and then I'm going to refer to that
as P LT as a shorthand similar to what
we did for numpy and for pandas so I
should also say that you should have
matplotlib installed and if you don't
have it installed you can just open up a
new terminal to make this a little bit
bigger and you can just run pip install
the matplotlib and this should install
everything that you need I believe this
comes with lump I already so you might
already have it installed if you haven't
done pie installed if you don't if you
want to be sure you can run the command
that I just ran which is installing
matplotlib you'll see that I already
have this requirement satisfied so I'm
good to go you might already see that as
well if you don't then it will install
on your machine and then you should be
good to go so just gonna close that go
back to our code here go back to the
bottom of the file which is where we
were previously writing code and then go
from there so again just to review we've
created a time series object using
pandas we've created a plot with some
specifications and then we're showing
that plot using the matplotlib that
python module so let's write this I'll
clear the terminal and then I'm just
gonna say Python visualizing Twitter
data that's gonna pop up a window or
should pop-up window it doesn't know
what data is I think the reason for that
is this is not this is not correct it's
not data it's date right so we want the
Y the X access to be the dates so that
was my mistake there right then again
try it again so we're gonna write this
and now what we have here is
sequence of dates along the x-axis the
number of likes on the y-axis and we can
see kind of how the number of likes
changes over the course of a given set
of dates so from however long ago we
were able to extract 200 tweet from all
the way to the present day of this
recording and then there's you know
maybe a few interesting things that you
can see from this graph there's a big
spike right here number of likes so it
might be interesting to drill down as to
why that is this whatever tweet this was
got you know just a head and shoulders
above every other tweet here so that's
that might be kind of interesting to
examine further so I'm just gonna close
that and then go back to our code so
that's the time series for the number of
likes but we can also do time series for
other things so it really we can just
kind of modify this code very slightly
to do let's say the time series for
retweets so maybe I'll take this I'll
paste this down here and then instead of
time like so let's call this time
retweets
let's also rename that so that's also
time retweets and then the series object
that we're gonna create we want to
create not with likes but with retweets
and the date is fine because we still
want to see how the retweets the number
of retweets changes over the course of a
given set of days this is fine we're
just creating the same plot and then we
just show it so let's just go ahead and
see I'm just going to comment this
initial time series out here the one
that we're doing he likes to comment
that out so we don't get too many plots
save that and then I run it so we should
get a very similar looking plot where
now we can see it kind of a similar type
of graph and this spike you'll notice
also corresponds to the same spike
probably where that huge that tweet that
was liked a lot was also retweeted quite
a bit too so you can see the number of
retweets here on the left side of the
screen the y-axis is much less than the
number of likes however the number of
retweets is in some way correlated to
the number of likes so that's kind of
interesting too so this tweet whatever
Donald Trump tweeted at this time seem
to have garnered a lot of likes and
retweets and it seems like the the graph
is somewhat consistent with the number
of likes and perhaps what we can do just
to kind of verify this hypothesis or to
of verify but to give a little bit more
evidence that this hypothesis is
probably true is we can we can bunch the
time series together onto one plot so
instead of plotting two separate time
series where we have one for the number
of likes and one for the number of
retweets one thing we can do is we can
just put them on the same plot and see
how they correlate so let's just go
ahead and do that so I'm just going to
comment this out and then what I'm gonna
do is I'm just going to copy this so I'm
creating the time series likes just like
we did before I'm creating the plot and
I'm going to change the plot actually
instead of doing the color and the fixed
size I'm actually gonna change this to
well I'll leave the fixed size I will
get rid of the color I'm going to add in
a label because we're going to have two
lines on this time series one is going
to be a label for the number of likes
and what is going to be a label for the
number of retweets so for this one this
is likes I'm going to put this line as
labeled as likes and that I'm also going
to put in a legend is equal to true so
this basically will put in a little box
in the the time series chart which will
show us what line corresponds to what
label and that's gonna be kind of
helpful because what's nice about pandas
and matplotlib is that if we plot
multiple lines here it will be smart
enough to distinguish them by assigning
them a different color and then what
we're doing here is we're essentially
just labeling to each of those lines
from whatever they represent and then
we're going to put in a legend which is
essentially going to correspond to this
blue line is likes this orange line is
retweets and it's gonna make it easier
for us to kind of visualize what's going
on so that will be a little bit more
clear when you actually see the graph
I think describing it without seeing it
is a little bit a little bit difficult
so anyway let me copy this right here
and instead of actually I'll just copy
this right here which is corresponding
to the retweets so doing the same thing
for the retweets I'm going to copy
that's thin here get rid of that so all
I'm doing here is I'm just making sure
that the plot is formatted the same
exact way as it is for the likes when it
changed the label here to retweets
so just to
for what we've got we've got our time
likes we've got our time retweets those
are both the series objects for pandas
that correspond to the time series data
that we want to plot we create a plot
for the time sorry for the likes we
create a plot for the retweets and then
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
one single plot that show call PLT not
show call and then that is going to put
the single plot up on the screen and
we'll see both those lines put on there
together so go ahead and write that and
then let's just run this to see what we
get so we get the two plots up against
each other so we've got the dates again
just like before and the number of
either retweets or likes of the y-axis
and you can see that right now we put
legend is equal to true that's giving us
this little box here in the upper right
corner of the plot so likes is denoted
by the blue line and then orange is
denoted by the the retweets is denoted
by the orange line so well we we can
kind of see is that there is indeed some
correlation between the likes of
retweets so first of all there's a lot
more likes than retweets but you can see
certain spikes that are eyes in the
likes also correspond to spikes that are
eyes in their retweets as well so that's
very topical probably something you
could have arrived at without doing any
sort of a plot analysis on it but it's
kind of interesting to see the data
being visualized like this this is more
just kind of an exercise in what you can
do using this type of data
analyze the sentiment of a given tweet
so we're going to determine whether or
not the sentiment of a given tweet is
overly positive negative or neutral and
for this purpose we're going to make use
of a module called text blob so this is
something that we'll have to install if
you don't already have it installed this
particular module has a built in
sentiment analyzer that's already
trained on data so we can just make use
of the analyzer itself to apply to our
tweets to determine whether or not
they're positive or negative based on
this on this text blub analyzer so first
and foremost let's just open up another
terminal and I'll make this a little bit
bigger what we'll need is this text plop
of things so let's just go ahead and
make sure that we have that installed
pip install text blob so if you do that
if you already have it installed you'll
see this requirement already satisfied
if you don't then you'll see it install
on your machine
once you've got that you should be good
to go so now that we have that installed
let me just close this we will go ahead
and import this so let's go ahead and
import this over here I'll say from text
blob imports the class text blob and
another thing that we're also going to
make use of in this video is a regular
expression and this will be made use of
to clean the tweet essentially to remove
any extra characters or hyperlinks or
things that are not necessarily
indicative of the actual text content as
part of the tweet we want to remove all
that because that's not necessarily
going to help us in figure it out the
sentiment of a given tweet so let's go
ahead and just import our e which is the
regular expression module in Python and
we've got everything ready to go so our
e should also already be installed on
your machine if you have Python so you
don't need to install that separately
you don't need to do a pip install or
anything like that so let's go to the
bottom of the file and I'm going to
clean up some of these things so I'm
going to get rid of these plotting lines
here so all of these were from the
previous video I'm just going to go
ahead and delete that I'm going to keep
the data frame creation because we'll be
making use of that specifically we'll be
adding another column which will have
the sentiment analysis for each tweet so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to add
some functions here in the tweet
analyzer class the first function which
I'm just gonna call it clean tweet will
make use of the regular expression
library to clean the tweet and remove
any hyperlinks or extra characters so
this is a member of the class it's gonna
take self and then also the tweet to be
cleaned so what I'm actually gonna do
since the regular expression is a little
bit cumbersome and verbose and annoying
to write out I'm just going to paste it
right in there and this is from a file
that I've already saved off to the side
and what I'm gonna do is I'm just going
to of course like I always do
have the code available on my github so
instead of pausing the video and writing
that whole terrible expression out you
can just download the code and copy from
there so again basically all that's
really going on here this looks a bit
complicated but it's just removing
special characters from the string from
the tweet specifically and then we're
moving into hyperlinks and then
returning the results of that clean
tweet so we have a function that does
that it's responsible for that now we
want another function that's going to be
responsible for calling text blob and
using the sentiment and Ally analyzer
provided from text blob and then
returning the sentiment so let's call
this function analyze sentiment this
will be taking self and then also the
tweet that we want to analyze the
sentiment of so we'll go ahead and
create an object that will be returned
to us from text blob we'll call this
object analysis and we'll set this equal
to text blob and then what we're going
to feed into this is essentially what we
want to analyze the sentiment of which
in this case is the cleaned tweet so
we're going to say self dot clean tweet
and then we're going to feed in that
tweet that we get into this function
make sure that it's clean passing the
clean tweet into this text blob thing
this class and then this will allow us
to leverage the sentiment analysis tools
the text blob provides to us so now what
we're gonna do is we're going to do just
that
so we're gonna say if analysis dot
sentiment dot polarity so what we're
doing here is analysis is the object
created from text blob there's a
function of that called sentiment which
will make use of the sentiment analysis
engine and then there's a further
function that's called polarity which is
a property of that analysis which
basically tells us whether or not the
the tweet in this case is positive or
negative so the polarity is a metric
of whether or not that tweet is positive
or negative in nature so if this
property this is greater than zero we're
gonna return one so this is to indicate
that the polarity is positive so it's a
it's a positively interpreted tweet so
we're gonna return one in that case so
else if the sentiment analysis about
sentiment about polarity if this is
equal to zero then we essentially don't
know whether or not it's positive or
negative so it's just going to be
neutral so if it's just a neutrally
analyzed tweet we're just going to
return zero to denote that so zero will
be the case when the tweet is just a
neutral tweet and then otherwise so
otherwise the case would be that the
polarity is negative and in that case
the sentiment analysis engine determined
that this tweet is actually negative so
what we're going to do to denote that is
return minus one so that'd be the way
that we make use of this function to let
the user know that the tweet was
analyzed to be negative so we've done
that we've gone ahead and created the
clean tweet and analyzed sentiment
functions so now we're gonna go ahead
and make use of them let's go down to
the main part of the this file here so
what we're gonna do just going to save
this what we're gonna do is we're going
to build on the data frame that we've
created from the tweet the what is it
called the tweets analyzer class so
we're going to build on that data frame
so we're going to add another column
which is going to be the sentiment
analysis for each of the tweets that we
have in this data frame so what we're
going to do is we're going to create I'm
actually just going to copy one of these
lines up here and then add it after this
one so really what we're doing is we've
created this data frame which again is
returned to us from this function as
part of the tweet analyzer class and
then what I'm doing is I'm adding
another column on to that data frame
which I'm going to call let's call it
sentiment and this is going to have the
1 0 or minus 1 depending on the
sentiment analysis of that tweet so what
we're gonna do we're gonna change one
thing in here instead of saying the
reach week we obviously don't want that
what we want in this case let's see I
think I delete it too much there
so what we want in this case is we want
to actually call our function so we want
to say tweets analyzer dot analyze
sentiment and then we're going to pass
in the tweet so we're gonna go ahead and
pass in that tweet and then we're gonna
be looping through each of the tweets in
the tweets list that we have here so
basically actually I it doesn't know
what tweets is so we need to specify
what we're actually looping through so
instead of tweets which is clear from
the function up here so tweets is
defined here but it's not defined down
here in the main so we want to specify
that we're looping through the data
frame that corresponds to the entry of
the column that has the column tweets
because again that is where we're
storing each of these each of these each
of the texts that corresponds to each of
the tweets so just to kind of unpack
what's going on here again we're looping
through each tweet in the data frame
column corresponding to the heading
tweets which is again created up here
and returned in this line here and then
what we're doing is we're doing a very
similar thing which will look familiar
if you saw like video 3 where we did
these things to kind of determine and
create new columns corresponding to the
IDE length date source things like that
we're doing the same thing only now the
value that we're storing it at that
column for that given tweet is the
sentiment analysis of that tweet and the
way that we're doing that was we're
making use of that function that we
created which is analyze sentiment which
returns 0 1 or minus 1 we're feeding in
that tweet it's going to get cleaned
it's going to get analyzed and then
we're going to have one of those 3
numbers so we have our new column here
which is the sentiment analysis so let's
just go ahead and make sure that this
works as expected
so what I'm going to do here is I'm just
going to print out the first 10 entries
in the data frame so I'm gonna say print
D F dot head and then I'm just going to
pass in 10 which is just letting Python
know that we only want to see the first
10 entries in this data frame so I'm
going to write that I'm going to clear
the terminal and then I'm gonna say
Python and the name of this file is
sentiment analysis Twitter data type pie
so if we do that it'll get the tweets
and then we see we have our data frame
here we've got our familiar columns and
then we also have the sentiment so we
have minus 1 for this first tweet it
looks like
that definitely could be phrases
controversial - one it looks like
there's not enough of that tweet is
showing there for me to determine
whether or not it's really controversial
that third one is neutral
congratulations argue maybe that's
positive
the next congratulations tweet here
that's positive so that makes sense
thank you thank you is it's repperton to
be positive next one is neutral but
vodka and the remaining tweets are
positive so from this very cursory
glance Donald Trump seems we can very
positive guy so yeah so there's that so
anyway that's pretty much it for this
video
if you have any questions or comments or
anything like that then don't hesitate
to leave them in the comments section
below as I mentioned before all the code
for this will be available on the github
and I'll have a link to that in the
description you can just download that
there so thanks again for watching and
have a great day